a lot of people come to Las Vegas
thinking sex work is legal here but it's
not only some Nevada counties allow
brothels in their borders but one man
hopes to change that 8 news now
investigator David charns learning
what's behind his mission and how this
would be regulated
have all your sexual experiences been in
brothels I've never had sex
um
non-commercial 32 year old Russell Greer
says he's always paid for sex something
Phillips accepted it's able to talk to
someone who'll listen to me and you know
it'll tell her someone yeah it means
everything the Salt Lake City native was
born with a condition leaving his face
paralyzed I can't close enough I can't
smile he now lives in Las Vegas and says
he's had difficulty dating in his words
Society has not been kind I don't see
what's so wrong with paying for it Greer
says he's fulfilled his need for human
connection at brothels across Nevada the
only state where sex work is legal in
some areas state law prohibits counties
with more than 700 000 people from
having brothels that includes Clark
County and Las Vegas individual counties
can also choose their own rules Greer
hopes voters in three areas will get the
chance to weigh in on legalization in
2024 he wants to go bigger in 2026. I
just feel like realized by where
everyone else or you know one of the
office is there are about two dozen
brothels across Nevada where sex workers
have to pay taxes and get regular STD
checks but there are none here in Las
Vegas but if they were to come here it
could mean big business in 2012 a UNLV
study found that in just those rural
counties the brothel business brought in
an estimated 50 million dollars a year
who's going to your Ranch everybody all
walks of life Tara Adkins is the Madam
at the Mustang Ranch in Story County
outside Reno you're almost like a mother
figure to these ladies about 50 some
with several clients A Day Men Women and
couples last Saturday we had about 150
in one day Atkins says a good portion of
that clientele is like Greer people who
aren't going to bars or using apps and
who want to know their partner is safe
what's it like fulfilling that need for
them for me
it is probably the best part of this job
is to make sure that that need of human
touch is met the regulations adkin says
are a big part of the job and an
important one when we hire some girls
that have been doing independent work
some of them don't even know how to put
a condom on and so we train them how to
use condoms do you think the work that
you do at the brothel should be expanded
Statewide I think more brothels would be
a great thing Dolce works at the ranch
she says the procedures in place
required by law could be expanded across
Nevada it means that I am safe I am
protected and I can always Stand My
Ground and demand respect I would like
to own a brothel here in Clark County
Greer Hope's legalization goes Statewide
reaching Las Vegas both as a potential
brothel owner into combat non-legal sex
work already happening here instead of
arresting people for doing that when
there's well includes on an auction to
do it in 2018 voters in Lyon County
chose to keep brothels in their
community in that attempt a group had
tried to rescind legalization any ballot
initiative requires two Statewide votes
and then legislative approval I'm David
charns 8 news now our 8 news now
investigators reached out to a group
that's combated legalizing brothels in
the past we did not receive a response
in time for this report